hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter veray today
we're going to be discussing what
happened to The Wizarding World after
the climactic defeat of Lord Voldemort
in the Deathly Hallows after a period of
total chaos a sudden silence fell over
the Hogwarts grounds the menacing Lord
of Darkness Voldemort was finally
defeated Victory brought a fresh morning
glimmer marking an end to the fear and
Terror that the dark lord had spread
across the Wizarding World but even
though Voldemort's Reign was short-lived
his time in power was more than long
enough to spread a veil of Darkness over
the once vibrant Wizarding World lives
were lost institutions crumbled and the
inhabitants of the Wizarding World were
reminded of what Darkness was capable of
and in times like this the darkest of
times it would be wise for The Wizarding
population to follow the sage advice of
Albus Dumbledore the man that always
reminds reminded us to turn on the light
Voldemort's defeat was a glorious
occasion for the good guys but as the
light of Victory settled a new and
colossal task dawned on The Wizarding
World the Reconstruction of a fractured
world and the healing of a society
bruised by Voldemort's regime but if the
Phoenix has taught us anything it's that
it is after the fall from the Flames
that we Rise Again stronger than ever
the ashes have defeated Fallen now it
was time for the magical world to rise
I've done a video in the past discussing
what happened to each and every
character from the series in the
post-war era but today we're going to be
honing in on Wizarding society as a
whole what happened to Hogwarts the
ministry of magic Diagon Alley without
further Ado let's uncover The Rebirth of
Wizarding Society new leadership during
the second Wizarding War even the
Wizarding world's primary governmental
body fell to the regime of Voldemort
this meant that following the ministry
takeover her Voldemort was able to
install Pious thickness as Minister for
magic replacing the previous Minister
Rufus scrimga who was assassinated at
the hands of the dark lord during his
time as Minister the imperialist pious
acted as Voldemort's puppet blindly
following his orders it s not entirely
clear what happened to thickness but we
do know that he participated in the
Battle of Hogwarts we also know that he
was stunned during the battle and
possibly later killed this but the
Wizarding World in a brief and unique
position where no Minister for magic
existed that is until Kingsley
shacklebolt was named temporary Minister
during his time as interim Minister
Kingsley was able to use his Steady Hand
and calculated mind to steer The Fragile
Ministry of magic through turbulent
times one of his first acts was to set
about the task of apprehending
Voldemort's remaining followers in order
to uphold peace and Security in The
Wizarding realm this task however was
far from straightforward many who obeyed
Voldemort claim to have been acting
under the imperious curse which led to
the arduous task of picking up the Liars
nevertheless Kingsley did quite a job at
reinstilling The Wizarding population's
confidence in its primary governmental
body Kingsley helped to implement
reforms Anchored In fairness equality
and transparency leading to a marked
improvement in the ministry's
relationship with the Wizarding
community and other magical beings which
had been strained under Voldemort's
regime crucially shacklebolt's era as
Minister saw the modernization and
democratization of the ministry that had
been overdue it allowed the scars of
conflict to heal and gave the Wizarding
World a glimpse of a future filled with
hope and peace under kingsley's Guidance
the ministry sought to cleanse itself of
the rancor and Prejudice that had vested
within its ranks mugglebones once
persecuted under Voldemort's regime van
Solus in a more inclusive Society where
their magical prowess was valued and
respected just as much as that of their
pure blood counterparts during his term
Kingsley helped rid the ministry of
corruption captured and imprisoned Death
Eaters banned Dementors from guarding
Azkaban appointed Harry as head of the
aura department and along with Hermione
mostly eradicated Pro pure blood news
because of shacklebolt's invaluable
contributions to Wizarding Society he
was eventually appointed as the 35th
official Minister for Magic a position
that he remained in for over 20 years
eradication of the Death Eaters the
sentencing of the remaining Death Eaters
was a large part of the Wizarding
world's next chapter namely as
identifying and bringing the surviving
Death Eaters to Justice was no easy task
after the first visiting War many Death
Eaters escaped the Clause of justice and
were able to reintegrate with Wizarding
Society undetected this time more
stringent protocols were put in place to
avoid repeating the same mistake twice
the likes of Lucius Malfoy who
frequently strutted the halls of the
ministry with arrogance were among those
who faced a series of intense
interrogations eventually finding
themselves with a one-way ticket to
Azkaban not every Death Eater received a
prison sentence though Severus Snape the
bravest man Harry ever knew was
posthumously exonerated unraveling the
intricate web of Voldemort's followers
was largely the responsibility of the
auras the ministry's bravest undeniably
became the Frontline soldiers in this
complex mission after the war Harry
Potter himself became an aura as did Ron
Weasley together they joined the ranks
of elite auras at the ministry and
worked relentlessly to root out the
remaining Death Eaters the trials of the
Death Eaters and the steady eradication
in the Voldemort's lingering influence
undoubtedly proved pivotal in restoring
a sense of security and progress within
the Wizarding World it also demonstrated
the resilience courage and determination
of a community that wished not to forget
its dark past but rather to learn from
it and aim for a brighter future
Hogwarts and magical education in the
aftermath of the battle of Hogwarts the
once a majestic grounds of Hogwarts
School were left in shambles the
landscape was scarred by the skeletal
remains of Smash debris and crumbling
infrastructure with what remained
serving as a constant reminder of the
immense destruction that occurred as a
result of the conflict they stood up at
once and together he Ron and Hermione
left the Great Hall great chunks were
missing from the Marvel staircase part
of the balustrade gone and rubble and
blood stains occurred every few steps as
they climbed but nonetheless Voldemort's
forces were defeated and the site of the
ruins also served as a poignant reminder
of the bravery and sacrifice displayed
by students teachers and Defenders Of
The Wizarding World and amidst the
wreckage something stirred the chance
for a new beginning and the opportunity
to rebuild a better world in many ways
the fall of Hogwarts represented not a
catastrophic end but rather the dawn of
a new era it was the closure of a
chapter marked by fear distrust and
division opening the path for
transformation unity and growth and who
better to guide Hogwarts in this new
Direction than Minerva McGonagall the
first step in bringing Hogwarts back to
its former glory was repairing the
grounds and restoring the protective
enchantments that made Hogwarts a safe
haven for young students it took four
months to get the school back to working
order at which point McGonagall was
appointed as the official headmistress
by the Hogwarts Board of Governors in
September of 1998 the school began
welcoming first years back to the school
and though the school was fit to
accommodate students there was still lot
of work that needed to be done Voldemort
met his demise on the 2nd of May in that
same year so all things considered the
turnaround time for the school was
pretty good and while the castle was
rebuilt Hogwarts and its denizens bore
the invisible scars of the war the most
blatant example of this being the fact
that nearly all the students were now
able to witness the thestrals that
pulled carriages creatures that we know
are only visible by those who have
witnessed death this served as a
constant reminder of what they had
survived to commemorate the battle
McGonagall hosted annual memorials
ensuring that the memory of that fateful
day lived on included in these memorials
were demonstrations on how to perform an
effective Shield charm as headmistress
McGonagall made revolutionary decisions
including providing extra guidance to
Michael Bourne students who are unfairly
targeted during Voldemort's regime she
was also quite Hands-On and closely
engaging with students of the school and
even carrying out duties such as sending
acceptance letters to admitted students
escorting First Years the Great Hall and
presiding over the Sorting ceremony and
tasks that she performed in her previous
role at the school one of the biggest
challenges however was filling the void
left by staff loss during the battle
with that said McGonagall certainly did
rise to the occasion successfully hiring
a new Transfiguration teacher Staffing
defense against the dark arts and even
eventually appointing Neville Longbottom
as a professor of herbology working in
tandem with Professor Sprout earning a
reputation as a successful and inspiring
headmistress Minerva eventually took up
residence in Dumbledore's old quarters
turning her study into a space filled
with the soothing Melody from a
self-playing harp she also continued the
tradition of contributing to the pensive
ensuring that her valuable memories were
accessible by Future Headmasters and had
Mistresses one major aspect of the
school's progression was ensuring the
four houses Gryffindor Hufflepuff
Ravenclaw and Slytherin were unified the
Battle of Hogwarts and Voldemort's
regime placed a considerable amount of
tension between the students of
Slytherin and the other houses however
the fall of Voldemort also presented a
valuable opportunity for Hogwarts staff
to educate students on the histories of
the four houses with more emphasis
placed on the past Hogwarts staff and
students were able to avoid making the
same mistakes which resulted in a much
more prosperous Dynamic moving forward
the previously tarnished reputation of
Slytherin house began to wash away as
the school and its Community learned
from past prejudices the sorrows and
triumphs of the past became crucial life
lessons ingrained in the curriculum
History of Magic once considered by many
to be a tedious subject gained Newfound
importance as it familiarized students
with the second Wizarding war and its
implications
broken families though the Wizarding war
was won it certainly didn't come without
a price families were ripped apart lives
were lost and homes were destroyed this
holds true for many of the families that
we became more intimately connected to
during the story but despite all of the
tragedy the healing of families and
communities was a vital and necessary
ingredient in the process of mending The
Wizarding World the Weasley family
perfectly exemplified this path to
Healing over the course of the second
Wizarding War they experienced
unimaginable tragedy they lost their
home they lost Fred and they all board
the traumatic scars of people who had
witnessed death first hand with that
said however they were able to lean on
one another during these dark times
embodying the resilience and power of a
family uniting to cope with such a great
deal of pain on the other side of the
spectrum we have the Malfoy family
though they might not have suffered as
dramatically as a Weasley family their
journey to Redemption and reparation was
no less daunting throughout the series
we saw the Malfoy's fluctuating between
power fear and disillusionment with
their dark Alliance in the aftermath of
Voldemort's defeat they had to redefine
their lives find A New Path and be
accepted back into the community the
Journey of healing encompassing families
and communities is one of pain and
progress as The Wizarding World picked
up the broken pieces and molded them
into a magnificently mended future they
were given a stark reminder that even in
the darkest of times there is light to
be found the restoration of The
Wizarding World can be aptly summarized
in the wise words of Luna Lovegood who
remarked things we lose have a way of
coming back to us in the end if not
always in the way we expect a new era in
magical media in The Wizarding World The
Daily Prophet is more than a source of
news it's a significant influence on
public opinion remember when Harry's
claims of Voldemort's return were
ridiculed in the paper or when the boy
who lived was labeled a disturbed and
dangerous individual those weren't mere
character assassinations they were
crucial pieces in the jigsaw of wider
Wizarding perception setting the stage
for Voldemort's triumphant return this
meant that following Voldemort's defeat
the magical media was not exempt from
Reformation under the reign of you know
who the ones revered daily Prophet had
morphed into a mere instrument of
propaganda it published Rita Skeeter's
highly embellished poison pieces and
blatantly denied Lord Voldemort's return
post-war the ministry's new
Administration demanded transparency and
honesty in journalism pushing the daily
profit to shed its bias and regain its
stature the post-war era also brought
with it a push for information sharing
between the magical and non-magical
world without breaking the statute of
secrecy of course with numerous
muggleborns having suffered and the
Voldemort's regime efforts to bridge the
gap between these two worlds became
Paramount initiatives included sharing
magical news through certain muggle
channels carefully disguised to avoid
suspicion in addition close contact was
retained with the Muckle prime minister
who happened to get along quite well
with Kingsley shacklebold magical sports
and entertainment before the Goblet of
Fire magical sports and entertainment
thrived in The Wizarding World however
all of that changed when during the
Quidditch World Cup chaos ensued and
Voldemort's Death Eaters made their
Resurgence known tyrannizing fans and
players alike with Voldemort's imminent
return game suddenly didn't seem quite
so important but with light triumphing
over Darkness the magical world
certainly didn't wait long to dust off
their old brooms and get back on the
Quidditch pitch what better way to heal
the wounds and reconnect with beloved
Traditions than by reigniting the
competitive Spirit of wizards and
witches alike magical creatures from The
Forbidden Forest to the Great Lake The
Wizarding World is filled with a myriad
of magical creatures and beings many of
which were implicated in the second
Wizarding War Voldemort by way of false
promises manipulated Legions of
creatures to do his bidding from Giants
to Dementors to werewolves standing in
opposition to them fighting for the good
guys were centaurs thestrals hippogriffs
and house elves the Battle of Hogwarts
claimed many lives but you'll be glad to
hear that they didn't die in vain right
after the battle of Hogwarts there was a
renewed interest in the rights and care
of magical creatures from Dobby's Legacy
inspiring a more compassionate
perspective on ourselves to Hagrid's
unwavering adoration for All Creatures
big and small the post-war era unveiled
a heartfelt effort towards coexisting
harmoniously with magical creatures the
aftermath of the war saw the magical
Community taking determined steps to
restore and preserve the magical
environment from cleaning up the
Enchanted Forest to tending to the
Whomping Willow there was an outpouring
of love for mother nature a humbling
reminder that magic is as much a part of
the environment as it is of us in
essence the post-war era sent a clear
message magical creatures beings in the
environment hold a vital throbbing heart
the core of the magical world whether
it's understanding the freedom craving
essence of house elves or valuing the
wisdom of centaurs a step back to admire
our magical allies is a testament to the
diverse and symbiotic Universe we dwell
in conclusion and that concludes my
exploration of the breathtaking
Resurgence of The Wizarding World
following the fall of the Dark Lord
Voldemort from the Reformation of the
ministry of Magic the rebuilding of
Hogwarts into the Valiant steps towards
living amicably amidst magical creatures
and beings the spirit of magic was
rekindled in a world that had borne the
brunt of he who must not be named is
there anything I missed in The
post-second Wizarding War era if so
please leave a comment down below also
if you want to find out what happened to
all of the characters be sure to check
out my video where I dive into the
post-war lives of 100 Harry Potter
characters Link in the pinned comment
until next time remember it is our
choices that show what we truly are far
more than our abilities